well on the eve of a vote expected to
acquit the US presidents of his
impeachment Donald Trump has come
face-to-face with Democrats who've been
seeking to oust him from office he's
just given his State of the Union
address and the House of Representatives
the same chamber in which he was
impeached last month ahead of the speech
there was an awkward moments with House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi will see brought
the charges of abuse power abuse of
power and obstruction of caen Congress
against Trump and he appeared to turn
away from her and she extended his her
hands well later Nancy Pelosi was seen
tearing up a copy of Trump's speech as
soon as the ER and a half long address
had wrapped up he made no mention at all
of his impeachment
during that address instead Trump used a
third State of the Union as a rallying
cry ahead of the November election
speech was titled the great American
comeback he concentrated on the economy
jobs and health care if we hadn't
reversed the failed economic policies of
the previous administration the world
would not now be witnessing this great
economic success well Trump rose in a
surprise guest Venezuelan opposition
leader won why do a spoke about standing
in solidarity with the Venezuelan people
but medoras grip on tyranny will be
smashed and broken here this evening
it's a very brave man who carries with
him the hopes dreams and aspirations of
all Venezuelans joining us in the
gallery is the true and legitimate
president of Venezuela wan guido mr.
president please
which back you and Tom spoke about the
u.s. assassination of top Iranian
commander Qasem Soleimani he said
soleimani was targeted because he was
planning new attacks against Americans
our message to the terrorists where you
will never escape American justice if
you attack our citizens you forfeit your
life well our White House correspondent
Kimberly hulka's is live for us at
Capitol Hill at Kimberly we're both
watching that speech there before we get
on to the symbolism of which there was
plenty just give us the main takeaways
off the speech for you what did you find
significance in that there were two
things number one that no matter how
much the president tried to avoid
impeachment and the fact that he has
been impeached it loomed large in that
chamber whether we saw it at the
beginning with the House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi when he snubbed her as he
exchanged the speech she centered her
hand he rejected it to the tearing of
the speech by Nancy Pelosi at the end it
is all that people are talking about in
this room right now the other big
takeaway from listening to the
president's speeches well he appeared
very presidential it was teleprompter
Trump not Twitter Trump railing at his
opponents what we saw there was
essentially the themes of his upcoming
reelection campaign he believes that
immigration while divisive in this
country is something that he is going to
continue to make the case for whether it
be cutting down on illegal crossings the
fact that he has not fulfilled his
promise about building a border wall but
still talking about the intention to do
so he also is touting what he sees as
some successes and there's no question
that even some Democrats would agree
with regard to the renegotiating certain
trade deals like NAFTA to the u.s. MCA
that was a bipartisan success this is
something that Donald Trump is talking
about but where there are differences
and I think we're really starting to
see this is in the area of what we call
in the United States the kitchen table
issues Donald Trump very much trying to
make this a cornerstone of his campaign
touting that he believes the low
unemployment is a significant success
what we're likely to see from his
Democratic critics is the argument that
yes there are jobs but the wages are
stagnant and that is something that we
heard in that Democratic response a bit
of a touch on so overall the the themes
of these speeches really the big
headline here the impeachment looms
large but also that Donald Trump is very
much out of the gate in terms of his
re-election efforts he he certainly is
and the economy was a big talking point
immigration these were all key notes
that are safe to say we're going to be
hearing quite a lot of in this upcoming
election campaign we even heard chants
of USA USA in four more years I mean is
this and the campaign's already underway
is it not absolutely and look at what we
have to acknowledge once again and we
saw that very vividly in the chamber
throughout the applause lines only half
of the room was standing up this remains
a very divided country Donald Trump is a
polarizing president there is no
in-between most people like his policies
or don't like his policies in fact some
of the like his policies don't
particularly like him but like the
results of those policies this is
something that Donald Trump's going to
have to work very hard on another thing
he's going to have to work very hard on
is reaching out to many people that feel
that his policies aren't for them voters
of color and we saw that and quite
pointedly whether it was a Super Bowl ad
that took place for the biggest football
game in the United States on Sunday or
whether it was in this speech where the
president acknowledged a number of
guests who were individuals of color he
believes have benefited from his
policies or even what he believes he's
done for historically black colleges and
universities even the low unemployment
in certain targeted demographics voters
of color if this is something that the
president really
seemed to be focusing on and it
acknowledges the reality that he has a
problem in this area if he's going to
win the white house he's going to need
those voters on his side right now I
think the acknowledgement by this
president as he launches his reelection
effort is that he doesn't have them on
his side right now he indeed kimberley
for night we're gonna thank you very
much indeed and that said trying to take
listen to what the Democrats have been
saying after Trump states of the union
Gretchen Whitmer was the person to
delivering the Democratic rebuttal to
president Trump's State of the Union
address she's the governor of Michigan
that's a key swing state in the upcoming
presidential election and in her speech
she criticized Trump's handling of the
economy it doesn't matter what the
president says about the stock market
what matters is that millions of people
struggle to get by or don't have enough
money at the end of the month after
paying for transportation student loans
or prescription drugs American workers
are hurting in my own state our
neighbors in Wisconsin and Ohio
Pennsylvania all over the country wages
have stagnated while CEO pay has
skyrocketed so when the president says
the economy is strong my question is
strong for him well with the Senate
expected to acquit President Trump in
the impeachment trial but they're also
asked Americans to judge senators on
what they do as we witness the
impeachment process in Washington there
are some things each of us no matter our
party should demand the truth matters
facts matter and no one should be above
the law it's not what those senators say
tomorrow it's about what they do that
matters let's get more on this night
from Derek Plummer he's a Democratic
strategist and joins us now live from
Washington DC good to have you with us
here on al-jazeera I was going to ask
you but the Democratic reaction to
president Trump's speech but I think
speaker Pelosi got there ahead of you by
tearing up the speech at the ends I mean
that speaking
volumes there it is I mean I think with
this particular state of the union we
saw a very very different atmosphere
whether it was President Trump not
extending his hand to the speaker or the
speaker you know I think motioning
throughout the speech her disapproval as
well as tearing up the speech at the end
it was a speech that was full of
theatrics I think a lot of it hollow but
they're the areas where there was you
know bipartisan support really was
around those stories of those Americans
who have made sacrifices and/or are
benefiting from the actions of Democrats
as well as Republicans well it suggests
you talk about the reaction to you at
the White House has already tweeted out
a reaction to speaker Pelosi there and
pointed out that with that speech that
she tore up includes those action of
ordinary Americans that the guest that
President Trump that he'd invited there
that's that the child who was born at 21
weeks and survived the the veterans the
military veterans and all this is so not
a worry that by it appearing so
disrespectful Americans might turn
against the Democrats for reacting in
that way I don't think so one if you
notice the moment when you saw
bipartisan applause from both Democrats
and Republicans or around those
Americans American moments if you will
whether it was the African American
woman and her child they're going to see
that scholarship you know I would say
that the save for the moment related to
the very controversial figure and Rush
Limbaugh I think you saw speaker Pelosi
and Democrats really applauding those
Americans that I think Trump really
tried to exploit as part of his speech I
think when one looks at his record
you know what Trump did throughout his
speech was really pepper in off the
pepper authentic stories of Americans
with things that just weren't true you
know the president has tried to take
credit for things that he just did not
do
he is quite frankly lied I've been this
honest about the impact of his policies
whether we're talking about the growth
that we have not seen compared to
President Obama
whether
we're talking about the number of jobs
that were created compared to Obama and
president Trump or whether we've been
talking about the african-american
employment rate which we saw decreased
dramatically under President Obama and
has slowed down under President Trump
and so President Trump has made a number
of promises I will say that he tried to
you know speak to what he said were his
promises but I think many Americans saw
through that it was a dark speech at
times it was a speech that I don't think
spoke to the the reality of his policies
and the impact that he has had moreover
I think those that have benefited under
this president have been those who have
generally benefited in general so you
know those Americans that are actually
able to afford to invest in the stock
market etc well we have to wait and see
what the American reaction that will be
but of course there were a lot of
feel-good moments in that speech with
notably when when he was reaching out to
the the guests the ordinary Americans
who were who were invited there and
president drops good salesmen he tells a
very good story he talks about how he's
supporting the economy supporting blue
collar workers he's determined to ends
the the specter of socialism in health
care and said these are things that it
seems almost like he's trying to take
the Democrats calls and a lot of these
policies and one thing we know about
President Trump is a good salesman and
it sells it very very well are you not
worried that the the Republicans are
going after your issues and someone like
Trump is actually appealing to the kind
of blue-collar core democratic voters if
you don't have the the right inverted
commas nominee you may well be seeing
many more state of the unions from
President Trump well what I do think
this is gonna be the last State of the
Union address that we see from President
Trump - I would also say that you know
when you look at his his polling numbers
he has not expanded his base of anything
he solidified his base and his policies
have not tried to expand to independence
and to Democrats so when you've looked
at presidents in the past what they've
done is they've actually implemented
policies and have tried to speak to all
Americans what you saw tonight was
president
really speaking to his base the fact
that you saw you know GOP members of
Congress chanting four more years in USA
I mean those aren't things that you
generally see at a State of the Union
and again you know red meat to his base
the Rush Limbaugh you know fo not not
not knowing that he was going to get a
Presidential Medal when the White House
released a press release so but I would
say is that Americans are generally
seeing through president Trump they have
he's never been in the positive in terms
of polling and I think what we're gonna
see in 2020 is a very very spirited race
on both sides but I do think that
Americans are exhausted by what they've
seen from this president they're
exhausted by it's not just how he does
the the work that he does whether it's
tweeting but I think they're also
exhausted by the divisiveness that we've
seen from this president this has not
been a president who's trying to bring
Americans together and that's
unfortunate okay well some good news for
people who are exhausted we are about to
head to a break at so Derek Plummer I
will have to thank you very much indeed
for sharing your thoughts and your
analysis here on al Jazeera